yeah I think I'm editing my body cardi B
proves she's not doing any of that video
the 27 year old took to social media on
Tuesday to shut down rumors that she's
photoshopping videos and photos of her
body before posting them online but in a
true cardi fashion she proved this is an
edit free zone by showing off her curves
IRL yet think up anything it just
doesn't before a thing a little [ __ ] I
don't know baby you know everything so
good
they asked me for a video oh yeah
although she isn't editing her body
cardis definitely gone through some
changes over the past few months
switching up her look to include a red
pixie do and a tattoo makeover
anyway but this was cardi also admits to
a few extra lbs as she self isolates
during the corona virus pandemic very
very strong meal hold on last month the
rapper shared her tricks to mastering
the perfect thirst trap pic by sucking
it in but let's be clear cardi looks
amazing whether she's sucking it in or
not cardi b's relatability is just one
of the many things we love about her
my thought of Mia when e t spoke with
cardi year she got real candid about her
body and the cosmetics procedures she
underwent after giving birth to her
first child culture and you just made
this big revelation about getting
liposuction why was that important for
you to share it was important to me to
share you know what a lot of people was
just like egging me on to do it even
though I was going to do it because I
really want to explain to people how
hard is the process I feel like a lot of
people look at girls on Instagram and
thing like oh they got a lipo done and
it was
easy and this is such a long hard
process it's almost like the same
process as after you give birth to a
baby and you seen your body change and
snapping it back it's the same way but I
will talk later about it more I don't
have a documentary uh maybe I should
start filming it right I should start
filming I should start filming the
process because this crazy
[Music]